The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So now we're going
to start Part (b).
First we're going to
read the question.
To which does an atom of argon
form a stronger bond: another
argon atom or an atom
of krypton.
Justify your choice with an
explanation, using narrative
or cartoons or both that makes
reference to the operative
chemical bonding.
So again, he's not just asking
you for one or the other, but
that you give an explanation
to show that you understand
the concepts that are
being tested.
Here we're asked: does argon
bond stronger with another
argon or krypton.
And some students were confused
by the usage of the
term bond here.
But remember that bond doesn't
necessarily mean a covalent or
an ionic bond, it can also mean
intermolecular bonds,
which we have been using in
Part (a), so it might seem
logical that we would think
about intermolecular
bonds in Part (b).
Now we need to look at the
specific species we are asked
to consider here.
Argon and krypton are both Nobel
gases, and what do we
know about Nobel gases?
They have complete octets; they
don't bond very often,
and so, especially
to each other.
Therefore.
we will probably be looking at
intermolecular bonds, as I
said before, but also
the weakest form,
which is Van der Waals.
We're looking at Van der Waals,
because each of these
are a mono-atomic species.
That is, they just are gases as
one atom of argon and one
atom of krypton.
And so, Van der Waals is the
only type of interaction they
can have. As I said in Part (a),
Van der Waals has to do
with the movement of electrons
in an induced dipole.
And what does that mean?
So, we're going to talk
a little bit about
polarizability.
And polarizability is basically
how easy is it to
induce a dipole into the
atom or molecule.
And because these are non-polar
atoms, obviously, we
want to think about what can
cause a difference in
polarizability between
argon and krypton.
So if you think about it,
we're going to do a very
simplistic model of the atom.
We have a cloud of electrons,
and to get intermolecular
interactions, we want to have
a partial negative and a
partial positive induced
in the atom.
And this can be due to just
spontaneous fluctuations in
the electron density or to an
external charge or another
molecule or something.
But here we have two non-polar
atoms, so we want to see which
one will inherently be
easier to polarize.
And so if we go back to our
two species here, we have
argon, which has 18 electrons
and krypton,
which has 36 electrons.
So based on our discussion of
polarizability, we can see
that krypton is going to have
a greater amount of
polarizability, because it has
a larger cloud of electrons.
Those electrons are bound
less strongly.
As we know from our periodic
trends, krypton is a larger
atom, and so we are going to say
that the polarizability of
krypton is greater than argon.
As we talked about in Part (a),
even though these had the
same type of intermolecular
bonds, if one of them exhibits
a higher difference in partial
charges as krypton will, then
it results in a stronger bond.
And so the answer here would be
that krypton has a stronger
interaction because it
is more polarizable.
And that because is important.
Remember, when you're answering
a question, you
don't just want to put down the
answer, you want to show
that you know why that's the
answer, and that you
understand the concepts.